este nuevo golpe de roca líder del
anterior golpe de estado producido hace
tan solo ocho meses que ha cambiado
dentro del ejército para que en este
periodo de tiempo polenry se han dado
damiba haya perdido el apoyo de sus
militares
Buenas tardes Rodrigo Sí el presidente
Pues el jefe de la junta militar ha sido
contestado por diversos oficiales que le
han reprochado convertirse más en un
político que en un militar han
contestado sus decisiones militares y
sobre todo lo que pasó es que la
situación militar ha empeorado en las
últimas en los últimos meses con un
nuevo ataque la semana pasada con
víctimas civiles y militares entonces
este descontento que provocó
probablemente este golpe de estado
dentro del golpe de estado
Y qué ha pasado en los últimos años en
burkina faso para llegar a esta
situación de inestabilidad Se está
perdiendo la batalla contra las
facciones islamistas
Sí desde 2017 la situación ha empeorado
cada año hay hoy en día más de 40% del
territorio de burkina faso que está
fuera de control con una presencia de
alcaída con una presencia del estado
islámico hay problemas de hombre hay dos
millones de desplazados miles de Muertos
entonces la situación es particularmente
grave preocupante En este país y estamos
hablando de razones antiterroristas para
esta nueva alzada Pero cómo ha actuado
la junta militar en estos meses para con
el pueblo burkinés ha habido algún tipo
de represión interna
no hubo pues estos problemas de
seguridad ataques en contra de los
militares ataques en contra de la
sociedad civil una falta de resultados
entonces militares y debates sobre cómo
actuar frente a este problema de
terrorismo saber si se debía hay debates
internos por supuesto de saber si se
debe negociar con los grupos si se debe
Buscar socios exteriores y un gran tema
va a ser en particular de ver si los
rusos intentan aprovecharse de la
situación aprovechar de la situación y
si el grupo Wagner que ya está presente
en el país vecino de Mali va a tener
presencia en burkina fasus sabiendo que
no tienen resultados tampoco positivos
en la lucha en contra de los grupos
terroristas en malí entonces la época 11
de ver un mejoramiento de la situación
de seguridad con este golpe de
y en cuanto al que sería el nuevo líder
militar El capitán Ibrahim trauré que
sabemos de su figura
hasta el momento sabemos que él hace
parte de unos oficiales que ya habían
participado habían apoyado al golpe de
estado pero que está contestando un poco
los actos políticos del actual
presidente hubo algunas controversias
también en cuanto a la visita que hizo
el Antiguo presidente Blas compadre que
hizo que vino en burkina faso Y eso ha
sido muy controversial porque había sido
condenado en el marco del proceso sobre
la muerte de su predecesor que había
sido el presidente zancada